so my name is nizang and i work at
mexico software research and today i'm
going to
describe to you some working
geometry of differential privacy
so in this talk i'm going to show some
nearly optimum private mechanism for
specific
linear queries and the union tools from
geometry
more specifically from convex geometry
okay here is sort of the overall
strategy first i will
introduce to you this central uh object
called the sensitivity prototype
and we will just look at it so
we look at it from the bottom we find
some
geometric quantity to bound the
difficulty of the problem
and we look again where is that
so from the up we also find some other
geometric quantity
to find the quantity of some solution
right
then we put those two numbers together
we look again
and uh they're the same they were done
so that's a plan
okay so here's the outline so i first i
describe the setup
then i will introduce a defined
sensitivity point on top
then i will give you all kinds of bonds
all right
so the setup here
so use the business linear queries over
histograms
right so what are the user data use the
database in our histograms it's a
vector in n-dimensional capital and
dimensional space
and you can think there are n kinds of
people right so
one kind is basically all kinds of
combination of attributes
and each x i in this vector basically
represent
the number of people with that
particular type
now what's acquiring so the linear query
will be just the count of weighted count
over
histograms right so mathematically
business you have another vector now
a is in the same capital dimensional
space
it's a low vector you just take the dot
product of this a and
x under your user data so of course if
it's just one query it's sort of
boring we are interested in many queries
so d
linear queries so in this case all these
queries we can put them together we have
a matrix
capital a right so then the query is
nothing but a times your data ax
so here is i'm giving you an example so
basically here
say we have a some type of people
it's the person's gender age
education background and the zip code
new scene
then the query can be counting all kinds
of things as you like you can contact
number
college graduates living in certain
areas and account
some people i mean the people with a
certain age are
sitting certain gender so those kind of
inquiry
actually represent a large very large
family of queries right
and for instance it includes the this
celebrated current inquiries and can be
useful for
many other scenes too because here we
allow all this
this matrix to be from from real space
all right so of course differential
privacy i have to define it
so maybe i i don't need to so anyways
so now here the the only important thing
is
what's labeling data so when we say two
neighbor
two data are neighboring so it means
that
they only differ by one user right so in
all language it would be
the two vectors has the l1 norm at the
most one
so this is actually a relaxation it
makes your problem harder
because uh if we think people are
we don't have fractional count they
should be different by exactly one or
two right
by some integer value but here i just
make the problem harder actually this
does not
affect the sort of generality of the
problem
up or no bound so then we say
a magnet is a private basically if two
points
they are neighboring then the basically
the distribution or the answer you give
produced down these two data sets would
be indistinguishable
right so depends on your notion of
privacy absolute absolute delta
of course the holy grail or the goal
really of all this work is
we try to we want to design a private
mechanism with minimal possible error
right so that's basically the setup of
the query model and
what i mean by so do the privacy so one
sort of wisdom
is uh so how do we design the
best private mechanism the worst case
arrow actually depends on
how sensitive your queries are right so
basically it's a change to your query
result if i change between two
neighboring data right
so when the with when there is only one
query this is easy to define
so basically if i have a query it takes
your
your data map to just one number right
so in this case
i can define the sensitivity as just the
maximum possible difference
between two query results for every pair
of labeling data
right so and we know once we have
sensitivity then we can have a nearly
optimum
mechanism by adding laplace noise okay
this is all
good but the question is what if we have
many queries
right so because if you have many
queries this query they
actually apply on the same data they
will be
correlations right how how can we take
advantage of the correlation
so this where we need to introduce this
notion called the sensitivity prototype
which captures all the the sensitivity
of multiple queries multiple linear
queries
okay so what's sensitivity pointer top
so basically uh again let's look at our
query is qx
equal to a times x right let's look at
what's the difference between two
adjacent data
it's nothing but ax prime minus ax and
since this query is linear i can push a
to one side i get ax prime minus x
this is the point here
you know if there's a pointer okay
okay all right can you see it
yeah good so then
by the definition of enabling data we
know that x
minus x actually has l1 ohm is 1
right so therefore we know if i change
x change my data from x to x prime my
answer would be
a vector like a times z where the l1
norm of z is one okay so this is just
the sort of algebraically
i write it this way so what it means
geometrically
so i just i can write a as common
vectors
i cannot see it anyways so we we can
write a as common vectors let's look at
what's all the possible sort of the the
the
other possible differences right it's a
times this is an
l1 ball right so by the way lq means
unit l q this is an alkyl norm
okay so so if i
write it out it's basically a sum of i z
i v i right here
z i is just a is a scanner and the v i
are these are the common vectors right
and of course since
they is from l1bo so all the absolute
value of zi
the sum is has to be at most one and you
look at this thing geometrically
actually it's just a convex of v1 v2 vn
and also their flip right so so
therefore
this poly top with two times and
vertices
actually captures uh the sensitivity of
the linear queries
right so why if i have two neighboring
data
actually the result of x prime will be
inside the result of
x plus this sensitivity point top
as shown in this picture okay make sense
so basically the sensitivity
point of will sort of capture all the
possible
if i know qx where qx prime is right
that's sort of the sensitivity
so here i'll give you examples uh here
is one matrix uh
it's like a cube right it's all one and
a minus one one
so if you look it up sort of carefully
this actually captures so-called one-way
margin query
so i want to sort of draw the
sensitivity part
of these queries and
so this four this guy is the origin
these four dots are actually just
four column vectors one one one one
minus one
one and so on right then of course i
also
like to flip them to the negative the
symmetric point
i get another four points right so one
one with flip minus one with
minus v will be this guy and i take
the convex body of this guy right this
is by the way in three dimensional space
right
so it's a cube right so
right this is the sensitivity point of
of this
one-way margin queries okay another
example is when i have identical queries
look a basically has three queries
they're all the same
so what's the sensitivity point on top
of this queries
if i look at columns there are only two
vectors two different vectors one one y
or minus one minus one minus one right
so basically this is a boring so that
it's like a nine segment
it's the sensitivity point on top with
sort of identical queries
right you can do other real numbers you
will get the same point up
all right so this is a sensitivity
pointer top
now as i said i want to make this as my
central
object because then i can apply all
these from geometry
so now actually i would define the
privacy with respect to the sensitivity
point of
just in the answer space right so how do
i do this
so basically now suppose you already
have your answer right it's forget about
the data
so then i also tell you a sensitivity
prototype is okay it's a
centrally symmetric convex pointed help
it does not have to be a prototype it
can be a
ball right so but the important thing is
it's symmetric and complex
then
a private marketing would be only
considering the answer space
what you have is the answer y in the d
dimensional space
then your market need to produce a
distribution in
again in your answer space three
dimensional space here is
one example right you have y and since
this is the density function your
so the magnetism would need to spread
this thing out
so we say a maximum is private
if for two points now the neighboring is
defined
in terms of the sensitivity prototype if
y prime is
in the y plus k then this two
distribution has to be indistinguishable
okay right so if this is my k
and if the y prime is here then i add
another situation
really you shouldn't be able to tell
them
all right so of course when i say they
are indistinguishable
it's sort of fluffy right so actually
the exact
definition here is absolute data
differential
privacy right so i assume everybody
knows
by the way when data is zero we call it
a pure privacy
or we can call it absolute differential
privacy
right so of course actually it's easy i
mean to achieve
privacy easily i just answered zero
right so then it's
it's private of course but
that the quality of that would be would
be bad how how we define the quantity of
our mechanism is basically in terms we
defined in terms of worst case
error of a mechanism right so basically
you take the expectation of your
mechanism your
your answer minus the true answer you
take the square of that
then you look at expectation that's then
you look at the worst case error right
that's defined as
the quantity or the arrow of a mechanism
so
under this form actually this is not
some strange form it's just two
squared loss which is commonly used and
it's like a variance right so basically
you want to find
private mechanism which has minimum
variance
in some sense because your m y the mean
of my may not be
equal to y although in the mechanism i
am going to present next is all
satisfies condition so
then once i define the loss arrow of the
mechanism i can talk about what's the
optimal arrow
with respect to any particular k right
it's just
minimum arrow among
over all the mechanism which is absolute
delta private
so of course the holy grail so the goal
is that for any given k
can you design an absolute delta private
end
such that your arrow matches the part
the the best possible
right that's sort of the the dream of
all this i mean all this sort of the
private mechanic design work
so now let's return to to this uh
example again
so we have two set of queries they have
different uh
sort of uh sensitive sensitivity poly
top
but if we just look at the individual
query they actually you
cannot really see which one is harder
right so if i just take one query out
from
a or from that matrix they are very they
look of
similar but if i look at the point of
they are very different
so actually the arrow is very different
too for the first case
for pure privacy in like in d
dimensional space
you have two dimensional cube this is d
cube that's the total arrow
you need but for this guy you need a d
only d arrow is much smaller
so really uh when the intuition is that
if your body is large
then the arrow is not right so the key
point is
how do you capture this iteration right
notch
so you need we need to find the right
geometric definition for this
okay so let me start with the pure
privacy case
and this is based on the work by maurice
and
canal and actually i think they started
the paper 2010 paper started this line
of research
on using convex geometry to sort of
solve differential privacy problems
so how do we do the lower bound first
so this is done by using a parking
argument
so the parameter works as follows so
suppose somebody tells you that i can do
very
well i have a mechanism which came to
arrow nothing
r right i do i put a square there is
because it's a squared arrow
so what you say you say no impossible
of course you need to see more so so the
packing argument is based
as follows i want to construct a large
set of data instances first they are
close
reasonably close with respect to your
sensitivity point top
right so if this is the case
then because your marketing is private
so all the distribution answers you you
give to me have to be indistinguishable
they have to be all over the place on
the other hand
i want to make sure the spots are far
away from each other
right so all these guys these points
they have to be separable
on the other hand they have to be sort
of all over the place
so this is impossible so what is called
a parking
argument basically you want to find a
large parking or
size eyeball inside somebody
the inside of your your sensitivity
point top
right so here is basically the execution
of this strategy right
so forget about the serum statement
let's just
see what we can do
just to follow what i just said right so
first i take my sensitivity point
top i scale it by three times
right how big is this say c is like
according to
is this number d over epsilon right
we will see why it has to be like that
then from this body
c times k we will find the maximum for
our
packing o by the way so the arrow is r
squared
okay so sorry i didn't mention that so
that's why we choose four
we want to make sure all these data
instances are far away from each other
right so if they are four are away from
each other then
we can draw a 2r radius ball around each
point and all these guys they're
disjoint
right so now let's think about the one
ball let's see what can happen to this
ball right
so look at the mechanism because
um we claim that the error of the
mechanism
in expectation is at most r squared
right but simply by markov we know
we need to put at least half a weight
inside of this ball
right otherwise we cannot do expectation
of 2r
on the other hand since
the mechanism is private if i look at
this point the origin
0 right how much weight i should put in
each of this ball
because it has to be private and because
we are dealing with a pure privacy
so the difference between the
probability has to be at most the e to
the c
right so you need to put like this much
weight
in each bone and of course all these
spots are disjoint
and your time timing them together has
to be at most one
right so now of course if you
the question is what's the largest
largest parking you can find there's a
simple boundary you just take a volume
bound
right you take your your body ck you
just pick any point
inside your body then you remove a ball
with radius 4r
right then if there's anything left in
this
convex ponyta you keep picking until you
cannot
take animal right so each time
i pick a point i remove a ball of this
radius 4r i can at most take this many
volume away from your body right so if
the body has much volume
you will end up with a large subtle
point so p is greater than this to one
string
the the the ratio right
so now if i plug this guy
into here i move things around because
this guy can move to the right
and since i sat say instead of epsilon
then
i i arrive at this
this form right so actually this
we can define this more compactly we can
define this
quantity as a volume radius of a convex
body so basically it's basically
so what's the radius of a euclidean ball
which has the same volume
of k right so now we got a lower bound
right so by packing argument so really
the important thing here is that because
you have we are dealing with pure
privacy so since uh we have very strong
composibility
property so even it scales to very large
size
we can still get some some little bit
probability there
all right so let's apply this
uh bound to some convex body we know
right so let's look at the l one bar so
what's the volume radius of l1 ball
actually it's the one root d um
right so let's look at the l2 bar first
i think it's easy so l2 of course the
volume radius is one right
it's just a ball and if l infinity ball
then it's much larger than l 2 but you
got to root d
right in general if you have l cube ball
this is
the volume radius and another
interesting and sort of point hope i put
here is a random point of
you pick a capital n vertices from the
unit euclidean ball
you ask what's the volume of this convex
body and the people in convex geometry
have studied this
and this is the bound okay so when the
when the number of vertices is small is
compare comparable to
to d right then you get a one bar it's
one overdue d
and if this guy goes to to like
exponentially large then
this guy basically the same as your
euclidean more and then it's one
right so then plugging this band we've
got a lower bound
for pure privacy with respect to
those convex those sensitivity points of
us right
good so we have lower bound now we look
at the upper bound
so how do we do upper bound so actually
uh it's just the classic mechanism
laplacian mechanism but we try to do it
in high dimensions
right so i'm not going to get into sort
of the details but here is
just the just give you alternate so
basically you want to sample your
your point according to this so-called
k-loan
basically how far away a point away from
you
measured by your sensitivity pointing
top right
so it has to go down like exponentially
right this is mechanical
mechanism in high dimensions so i
this is sort of when you to define this
photo properly you need to do write an
organization
in this gamma distribution all this
stuff but you can just think it it's
just a univ
uniform sampling from your answer y
plus d over epsilon times k right so
basically it's it's a random symphony
from do epsilon over k
l times k uh this body which this deal
absolutely happens
to be the scale factor we use the lower
bound too
so why is still optional because if we
look at this body if we grow it right
so the volume of this guy will grow like
exponentially
uh in this like in d right because the
d dimensional uh body right so
therefore if i want to sort of offset
those
volume growth so when can i do that only
when this number is greater than d
right or in other words when the
this k norm is at most d or epsilon then
out of this guy because now the other
factor the exponential factor will take
over
so since it will become uh magnitable
right so this is basically the kingdom
mechanism right so it's easy to argue
that this mechanism
is a pure private so
basically the the argument follows the
same as laplace
the phone is same as an appliance
mechanism
we just use the fact that the knob is a
norm so you satisfy triangle inequality
so it's private what what about the
arrow as i said i
said earlier so we just this can be
viewed as a random sampling from above
size do epsilon times k right from
lattice sensitivity point on top
therefore the arrow is capital o of
d of epsilon squared and the expectation
of a random point
the l to norm squared of a random point
inside the ball
right so earlier we said
this is our lower bound and the other
guy is upper bound
so if somehow uh this guy
is upper bounded by the volume radius
then we're good we're done then we get
an
optimum business up and down on the
match
so again let's check our sort of the
this
sort of this
convex uh body as i i did before
so if i look at the expected x squared
actually it turns out to be
exactly match uh because it's squared it
exactly matches the square of the of my
lower bound
so actually in this case i guess get the
exact optimum mechanism of course within
constant
right this is nice but
maybe this is just coincidence right so
is this a coincidence
um actually this question whether the x
square is
bounded above by volume radius this has
been studied
in convex geometry so
basically i'm not going through all
these sort of definitions
basically there's one quantity you can
define
with respect to any convex body it's
called isotropic constant
right so if your isotropic constant
is uh bounded above by constant then we
know that is true
right so there's a conjecture by
ah sorry i i need to
so isotropic constant if if it's a
constant
then that statement is true of isotropic
bodies when
a body which is a scale such that its
covalence matrix is a
multiple identity matrix
so uh actually
this has been we don't know if this is
true or false
but this has been conjectured uh in
convex geometry that
it is true this is a sort of thirty year
open problem
and it's called a hyperplane conjunction
so why it's called hypoplant conjecture
because
this statement actually is implied by
the
other more intuitive statement which is
that if you have a unit
convex body you need volume contacts for
in any dimensional space right d
dimensional space
then you can always find the slice of it
meaning
a d minus one dimension cut or your
convex body
which has above constant area so this is
a
so-called hyperplane conjunction which
is still open
but it's true for like lp balls for
random prototypes
and the people they they think is i mean
i think
the general option is it's probably true
uh but
we the best number is due to one quarter
so
uh here is the first the theorem sort of
the
uh then proved in this numbers and class
paper that is
if the hyperplane conjecture is true
then the keynote mechanism isn't the
only optimum
for isotropic tropical k right
and this sort of actually the conjugate
conjuncture can be removed
by some network actually also they use
some work by from again from convex
geometry that everybody
it's always close to another convex body
with
constant extraordinary constant
so okay this is good
but of course what about the
non-isotropic bodies let's look at this
this this
set of queries right it has a very
skinny sort of sensitivity pointed top
and it's not
isotropic and if we apply what we did
to this convex body will be in trouble
right
first first problem is that the lower
bound will be useless
we have a nine segment his volume is
zero right we don't get anything useful
what about the upper bound i want if i
add the laplace noise to this guy
i will get an arrow d cubed right
so basically the length of this guy is
root d right so
if i i i look at this one dimensional
problem i need to
add if i talk a square arrow that's d
then i need to because i have a scanning
factor of d squared i get decubed
so those two uh two to distance
uh to fix the first problem you can
actually look at define
look at the low dimensional projection
of your convex body you can define
the volume radius in a lower dimensional
space like in this guy for this guy we
can look at the one-dimensional
volume radius it's root d right for the
other
sort of one you can do some
decomposition basically try to find your
principal direction the lung direction
then you reduce your problem to a lower
dimensional problem
and you're putting these guys together
then
it can be shown that this recursive
kelon mechanism
is logarithmically optimum so i'm not
going to
get into the detail here but the daytime
for the approximate privacy i will give
you more details
the idea is sort of similar all right
so i think we're done for pure privacy
okay let's look at the approximate uh
privacy
and this part of the talk is basically a
based on work by
sasha kunal and myself
and okay again this bad guy
that guy now says oh you if you want to
do lower bound now you cannot scale
because for approximate case
what does this guy mean so
when we have absolute delta privacy it's
approximate privacy
then we cannot really scale it so still
we can argue that to distributing a
similar
so actually what we can really scale the
the largest factor we can scale is only
log one over delta over epsilon but for
the lower bound really we needed the
geo-optional
scanning factor right
yes okay i will try something else i
will reconstruct
so what does this guy mean so the
reconstruct attack is a
basically if your arrow is too small
then i can basically guess a constant
fraction of your data right
although i don't even process precisely
know which
which is the character which is wrong
right
but this would violate the privacy so
here is basically the exact statement
so if you have a database oh sorry
if i can construct a procedure called d
such that for whatever answer you give
to me i can recover your data
uh up to a constant fraction of accurate
up to a constant fraction of error right
so and this data
has to be just the binary data you just
think your data is zero one
one normal your data is bounded by a
small n and then
if i take your answer and run through my
my data if i can claim that a one loan
of your true answer is with a high
probability
with more than constant probability is
smaller than some constant fraction
right
so if there is such a d then m is not
absolute data private um
this reconstruction attack i think it
first appeared in the new nissan in 2003
then uh i think the latest version i
presented here is
due to embassy and and social
and they used some early results of this
set of people and also
that's result all right so this is
reconstruction
attack so by using this construct
reconstruction attack we can construct
the so-called spectral lower bound
for approximate privacy right
so now again i need some definition
i need some geometric quantity so if i
have a set of vectors
you want to um those are kind of vectors
i can define the
sort of the minimum signal value
of this subtle vector is just
the mean of the of the
the norm of the vector after the the
norm
of the the vector when i apply
my transformation mu right so this is
nothing but just minimum signal value
then now i claim that if your
sensitivity pointed off
is like this it's u times some l1 ball
then the arrow has to be
at least m times the this uh
the singular value squared right why
because if your r is too small then we
can run
a reconstruction attack as follows
if you give me the answer
i just try to find a binary vector such
that ux prime is the
closest to your answer right sure
this may be it's quite hard to to find
let's see actually yeah this is probably
hard to find
because this is discrete but i don't
care because i
just want to say that you find nature
the privacy right
so to see why this uh violence
why this procedure works let's just go
through some mass
so uh since you tell me
with a high chance the distance between
your
your answer and the choice is small
right it's bounded by
by root n times sigma because this
squared error i need to
take a square root right so with a high
chance
it's the distance of between your answer
and the chance is small
and then i know my reconstruction
has to be closer to to to to your answer
than your
your true answer right because by
definition i take the argument
so again i just move this bond here it's
still
u time times sigma right
so just by just by triangle
triangle uh inequality then i know the
distance between my reconstruction and
the true
answer is bounded by u times sigma u
and because the minimum signal value is
at at least the sigma
i know the l2 norm between these two
data is
at most the root time right because
those guys are binary vectors i know the
the one difference is uh is a
neutral over right therefore the
reconstruction attack has worked
then you are this maximum is not private
um oh by the way feel free to ask
questions
ask questions before you you go to sniff
so okay
but of course if i have a sensitive
sensitivity point of
what should i do i should find m
vectors if i want to have a past and
lower bound i should
find the this sat
inside this point top which has the
largest
minimum singular value right so this and
we call it the spectrum
spectrum lower bound of course here
although as
you can pick any number of vectors as
you like but you shouldn't pick more
than d
of them right because you are all this
your point of view is indeed dimensional
space you pick the plus one points
then it becomes degenerate then the
minimum singular value is
zero right you don't get anything useful
right so again let's apply this notebond
to our favorite
convex bodies so if it's a one ball
we just take the standard base then we
know the
the minimum single value is one
and if it's l turbo again it's one
and if l infinity board is root d and in
general for l cube you got this number
if q is smaller than two you always get
one
if q is greater than two then you get
something between one and root d
and for random point of inside the
euclidean voice one right because you
cleaning boys one
already so from here we can get a
sort of saturn lower bound d d d squared
right and enter d okay so the one inch
in fact
notice that it's for l1 and l2 it's the
same
like the pure privacy case
all right we have lower bound what about
the upper bound other one again we run
our classic
maximum gaussian mechanism right for
approximate privacy
but of course we need to do it in high
dimensions so first i will
just say how to do this for for
ellipsoid that's easy
suppose your k is just a lip solid with
axes lambda 1 to lambda
lambda d and i also assume your
initiator is so to access the line we
have rotated
the gaussian mechanism is nothing but
you take your true answer you add a
normal distribution right with this
covalence matrix
diagonal is number one square to lambda
d square
times some factor depends on absolute
data
and we can show that i mean i guess this
is
well known that this machine is
is private so what's the arrow is this
mechanic it's simple right it's just
just the variance the sum of the lambda
squared
okay so now
if my body is not a ellipsoid it's some
k so what should i do
so to run the gaussian mechanism what we
can do is we just find the ellipsoid
to surround your body right then we just
then we apply the
the gaussian mechanism right so then we
know it's for sure it's
it's private but of course there are
the many of you nipsoid that you can
choose from which one you should
choose we say you should choose a
ellipsoid
with a minimum volume right also called
minimum volume in closing ellipsoid or
your convex body we will say why
we want to do this then okay so
basically here is
the so-called mvg gaussian mechanism
that's right so
right so why it has to do with the sum
of squared
okay we'll see
so the this is just some simple factor
volume minimum
volume increasing in nubus it's also
called the chunks in inside and it's
unique for every
convex body and
now we do some analysis of this
mechanism right
first is the privacy the privacy is
obvious because we know it's private
against
this surrounding body then it has to be
private against the smaller body
right just by definition what about the
arrow all right as we said
earlier it's just sum of i of i squared
so let's look at the either case first
so
let's say assume that your mve or your
convex body is actually you is a
ukrainian ball right so basically all
the axes that have the same length then
in that case
this can be just d times the
radius of the of the ball right
so now again let's apply this upper
bound
to our favorite objects so for l wombo
the minimum enclosing episode is a unit
ball
so the radius is one for l two ball it's
just itself it's again one
and for l infinity ball you got to root
d and
this is for l kill ball and for random
pointy top you get one again
then you do a d times the square of this
guy
you get a certain number here which
matches
exactly the lower bound right
so um
again is this a coincidence actually i'm
going to prove to you this is not
so if the this is a statement if the
minimum increasing
of a convex body is the unit euclidean
ball
then this mechanism is nearly optimum
okay with a constant
that's the statement i'm going to prove
first we have this lower bound this is
spectral lower bound
right this is our upper bound because
the m
the minimum in in closing left side is a
unit ball so
the summation of this guy is d right we
got a one in each direction
and by the way of course this is if you
scale it you shouldn't affect anything
because
it would scale all these numbers in the
same way
so now suppose
we can find the d vectors in this convex
body
such that the minimum singular value of
the matrix spanned by these d
vectors is omega 1. then
we can plug this lower bound into this
sky
we got omega d right
this guy is y and m is d then we are we
are done
the question is can we do that
so again people in convex geometry they
have studied this problem right so this
famous result by booking and suffering
uh actually uh just the sadness
uh this is true so
uh what is this uh so
to introduce
the theorem so i need this first uh uh
definition so
for several vectors right m vectors by
the way by presenting
here i want to make it more geometry
right in the paper we wrote is more like
a
algebraic but here since it's geometry
so
so we see a set of vectors we call it a
data white
okay uh if for every point in this
this vector set in this set of vectors
you look at the distance from this guy
to the subspace expanded by the other
points
if the distance is at least the delta
distance
is just the closest distance between the
point and the subspace
if this is true for every point in your
data set then this side is called a data
wide
okay makes sense
all right so then the theorem of bugging
on the suffrage sad
although his already the original
statement is more
like a from functional analysis it's
more algebraic
but actually this is identical to what
you said so
if you have a set of vectors which is
that white
then you can always pick out a constant
fraction
of these vectors from your set
such that the minimum single value of
this subset
is omega delta okay so this is
actually the proof is uh is elementary i
would say but
it's sort of uh clever so this is the
classic result
so then we need to combine this with
another
property of minimum value minimum volume
enclosing
ellipsoid that is if the minimum
enclosing ellipsoid over convex body is
a unit euclidean ball
then we can always find the d vectors
omega d
vectors in this convective body which is
omega 1 white the reason is that if you
cannot do that
you can always squeeze your ellipsoid
such that it has smaller volume
right so
then combine these two then we can show
that
first again if your mve or your convex
body
is the unit ball we can find the omega d
vectors which is omega 1 white right
then we apply bugging temporary
we can pick out another constant
fraction
out from u such that the minimum
singular value is omega 1 right because
this guy is omega 1
white now we're done
right because remember our goal is
whether there exists
omega d vectors in your body such that
its minimum signal value is one
okay right
so of course
that's when the minimum volume in
closing in episode is a unit pole
but if it's not a unit right if it's not
a unit or you have some kind of skinny
or
a skinny object then again the same
problem for the pure privacy exists
so you don't get a use for that so here
what we can do is we can do this
so-called recursive
uh gaussian mechanism so what we do is
we just again we kind of compute the
minimum volume in
enclosing the epsilon of the sensitivity
point top
and let's say it's access our aligned
this is the result loss of generality
because we can't always rotate it
so then we got the axis and this is
lambda 1 to number d let's see it's
ordered
decreasing right so then we can just
apply the gaussian mechanism
to the sort of the the smaller part is
the oval two-dimensional part we can add
the
gaussian noise there times some constant
i will tell you what constant
and what constant this factor should be
later
and then what we do for the upper part
we just recurse
on the projection to those the top
d over two directions right
then we take the result come back from
that
recursive code then i just return the
summation of this to
d1 plus z2
and by the way this is sort of similar
to the
the the knock classic uh mechanism for
the pure privacy case when the body
and the what is not in isotropic
position
so that's first the privacy analysis so
we know each level of this
mechanism is private and how many levels
are there they are not deniable
because every time we take a d over two
when after we deal with two dimensions
and so on
we only have no numbers so basically we
need to
run log these certain mechanisms if i
set c
to be not d times your private
sort of factor absent data here then by
composition theorem
then we know the recursive marginal
reason is private right
so what about the arrow right the arrow
if let's just look at what the arrow
included by z1
on the first column so basically it's a
summation of the other smaller
axis squared
we because we know this num does the
order decreasingly we can just
say times d times the largest one right
and on the other hand now we are we want
to use we can use the
the big part the top the over 2
direction to to produce a lower bound
and again this is the byproduct of 3
actually a refinement by
visioning we can again say there exists
omega d vectors in in k
such that the minimum single value is
bounded by the
minimum axis length in the top d over
two
uh parts so basically we got this
bond d times lambda d over two squared
right so this is our upper bound this is
the lower bound
and we know for one level this is the
arrow we
incurred which we know c is proportional
to log d
we got log d times function lower bound
right
that's for one level we need to do is
log d numbers
right which is some login level this is
a serum
that is recursive uh gaussian magnet
is not d squared option
so okay let me see some words about the
computational complexity
so for the pure privacy case we need to
compute the covariance matrix or convex
body
then we need to sample from convex body
and compute like the
isotropic bodies this all can be done in
in polynomial time or maybe
approximates within the desired accuracy
but it's sort of high polynomial right
the minimum inclusion uh in difficult
action is he there and
his convex uh programming and
hashem the he has a nice argument to do
it
this problem is actually there and in
practice
actually you can even do actually an
enclosing ellipsoid will do the work
right so
maybe it's not as good as like
minimal so it may work well for instance
you can just find the singular direction
of your convex body then you can just
shrink it
to so that it includes your convex body
you can use that in lipstick too and
this is sort of easy
right so all right so this is a
contribution complexity
now i have all this since in a single
table so
uh this is for our favorite convex
bodies
they all match right it's not of course
there's maybe a constant difference
because it's all these magnum with a
constant
factor of the of the optimum and we also
know for arbitrary k
it's not squared the optimum right
so i want to raise some attention here
that is if we look at the gap between
epsilon differential privacy and the
absolute delta right if i look at the pn
this is the convex body with two times n
vertices
so we can say that the gap of log 2 and
over d
right so if n is like a
this constant is d like l1 ball there's
no difference between absolute absolute
delta
and if your convex body has to be
defined by
say exponentially many vertices like l2
ball right
you will see a gap so is this gap
tight actually we can also in our work
we show that this
gap is not just possible but in order to
prove that we need a stronger lower
bound
it's the discriminancy or determined
determinant
lower bound okay so we have answered
this sort of
so many questions about the linear
queries
seems we can claim victory so
but the bad guy comes again so he said
but your value is useless when
population is small
right and by the way have you heard of
bmw
so what this guy really means is that if
your population size is
small you spin it up to n
then for counting queries you can answer
zero right it's a trivial mechanism
what's the error of this
this mechanism is in squared you off
and stop at most n square arrow right
for each query
because the l1 ohm this guy is
n and it's counting query so the the
size of each query is at most
n so the boundary is d times n squared
and what we got is d cube or d squared
depending on it's
pure or it's approximate so when d is
not
for pure is nothing and for a person
much saying
root n squared then this boundary we got
is useless
actually d n square is a very precise
mistake
and the private multiplicative weight
maximum by
uh morris and guy actually can do even
better you can
d times n times not half of capital
recurring queries what do i say so we
say okay
and then i will apply machine learning
to reduce
arrow okay so this is a sort of useful
recipe
so it works as fullness
so now we have some public knowledge we
know the population side this is funny
by little
detail right what should we do
we don't do anything special we i mean
to this with respect to this fact
what we do is we still apply or
unconstrain
private mechanism right we get our
answer
once we have the answer now i know the
answer has to be
to be in this smaller site the
constraints at c
and if the size of the population is
neutral and we know it has to be
in n times your sensitivity point on top
right what should we do we should just
apply
your favorite statistical estimation
algorithm
to reduce the noise on the answer with
respect to the constraints
the ground to set say anybody can do
this right
this because it says the public
information so even the queries you can
do this basically there's no privacy
violation
right so for a particular problem
so for the unconstrained part we just
use whatever we had before
we do this if the pure privacy we do
know
if it's approximate we do mini gaussian
mechanism then for the statistical as
numeration part we do the least square
estimation right
so now i take your answer i know
uh your answer has to be in a consumer
site i just find
the the the point that the closest to
your annoying answer
i just do this and turns out this sort
of
simplicity approach actually can be made
near the optimal
for sparse database if your population
size is bounded in particular
for counting queries it matches the pmw
right and even more we our method works
for pure privacy
and their method only works for the
approaching approach
meter privacy but the caveat here is
that we do
l2 squared error right it's a total of
average arrow what you do is with large
probability they got a sort of l
infinity the worst case error so
that in that sort of aspect
the bmw is still better
okay so actually this work i like to say
actually motivates the following sort of
thoughts so again this is the same
recipe i presented before but what if
the number of people is not a public
knowledge you cannot reduce the number
of people this is private
uh instead what you can do you can
release your constraint site
privately right for instance you can
release the number of people
uh by using your knock-knock mechanism
so basically
so the number of people is just a
accounting query so you just work
really hard to make sure this query
gives you good results
right so then you can apply your
unconstrained mechanism then you apply
your machine learning
and then even you don't know the number
of people you can still get some bumps
that depends on the number of people
right and you can imagine you can swing
other constraints
so we can actually show some extra
goodies
so by using geometrical tool and if it's
a sort of a non-sparse case
by doing some kind of boosting like
technique
we can achieve an infinite error and
also
you almost got to the whole talk without
calling it the sparse and the non-sparse
case can you because
because you're created by non-sparse
ah okay so
historically we call
a database with a bounded number of
people
at most literal people's sparse case
because somebody a guest is kunai
who called the unconstrained case
ben's case and
and if they just teaching in the
audience they will see this nonsense and
the sister said it's nonsense
anyways histogram is first that's what
you see well
with respect to what so i guess that's
the
most entries are serious okay you guys
should
fight now you can have anyways
if you start to stop calling the
mechanism you're going to be talking
about randomized response
okay so i guess that's the sort of kind
of i'd like to sort of
sort of describe several open problems
so the first obvious problem is to close
the gap right so for the pure privacy
there's a gap of not d
squared of three half it's a polynomial
d it's a gap
but it's not that bad because the number
of currents typically are not
that large it's wrong
it's the wrong definition if you have a
ton of people and they're all in the
first cell of the histogram then the
histogram is sparse
but little n is very very large and you
don't mean
the sparse results here you mean the
dense results there oh okay
but actually in that case so even if you
have
zero sparsity you can zero
isn't even if you have nonzero entries
you can still
do the projection because the number of
people yeah i think in
statistics when you say sparse means
non-zero entry
is small compared to the dimension
capital n right
so newton should be much smaller than
capital n
in all cases actually when we say sparse
we mean little n
has to be smaller than d
or root d the number of queries so
i guess we have to admit it's not
accurate
but as long as everybody understands
okay next time i fix it
all right but for sparse database
actually there's a is
since i mean the situation is about is
what's there so we i think the gap
involves and in addition to some action
of the
polynomial defect there's a root log n
factor
and an is a number of different types of
people can be very large
so if capital is notch then this
cup could be much and i so
like to mention there's recent work by
these three others and the wine is
sits in northern strong so they actually
showed that
if the i don't i mean their favorite is
the community described in some
different language
but if you decode decipher it so that's
what it says if your sensitivity point
off
happens to be l infinity ball or in
other words it
represents when we imagine queries this
root log
n factor is necessary but
the question is can we do this more
generally for some arbitrary linear
queries right
so the second question is what about the
other other arrow metric
so we do l2 squared you can imagine your
favorite
arrow magic so in this this problem here
is because
this might be a no harm through it
because uh
so here you know lower bound album proof
we all use like a ball packing or dip
soil stuff the reason we do all this
because
we are dealing with l2 bones so
if you have some other arbitrary norm
you should point to the packing or
covering
with respect to those kind of long under
the convex geometry guys they may
already have an answer
or to us for for answering these
questions
because the third part is uh here we are
assuming we see all the query
settlements
then we work hard on this queries what
if this queries become online one after
the other
in some situation we can do some
something like for instance for this
class as
estimation this can be made online so we
can imagine the
pmw bound for in terms of l2 to arrow
but if we want to do it more generally
and like
those tasks like minimum volume closing
deep soil recursive decomposition all
this stuff
how to make it make it online is not
clear and of course
we measure the online error we can
compare to the offline setting oh just
compared to the optimum online setting
do we have more okay so the last one is
uh
for counting queries when for linear
questions we know if we renew
this number of people so what would you
call it
instead of spas okay anyways
so so i i would partition into
many queries versus two queries but it
has to do with queries versus number of
people
okay because that's what sure that's
what it is really means
right so if there are many queries if
there are a few people then we know
release number of people actually can
improve the accuracy dramatically but
this is nothing but just accounting
query right so business this single coin
inquiry
you know the result or you work very
hard get very accurate on this
particular single query actually can you
put accuracy
of all the other adaptive whatever
arbitrary current inquiries
so of course one sort of
interesting question is uh can come up
with other constraints
to to help you reduce error
so to summarize i think that's my last
slide
uh explain geometry for differential
privacy first it's fun
and you're getting to read all these
papers in convex geometry and it's very
useful you can get into any option
found at the end i'd like to first thank
cynthia and claire for asking me to give
this talk
and also for helping me to prepare this
talk and of course thank everybody for
listening
all right
questions
this comes back to um i guess ashwin's
talk yesterday
was he was talking about sort of
different types of changes that you
could
like rather than thinking of the l1 ball
you can imagine a different
you know set of acceptable changes you
take the convex all of that
you know if i understood you're not
really using anything specific to the l1
ball here right
which is the image of the convex hull of
the acceptable set of changes
the important thing is that it has to be
the same in all the places
so that's right so you just need
a query so if you have different eggs
the sensitivity point obviously will be
the same
so if you have none none in aquarius
like quadratic or what
so you got some shape right that defines
the sensitivity you can always do that
that's maybe it's not complex or maybe
it's convex whatever you got
but when you move this point answer this
instantly
gets a bit deformed right so
it becomes trickier so what what ashwin
said
in his talk yesterday was that or
whenever it was
uh was that there was sort of a generic
transformation
at least with respect to some measure of
optimality the optimal
mechanism for some class of mechanisms
i'm not sure i understand exactly which
class
you could obtain the optimal mechanism
for
uh you know this variant this
restriction of
relaxation of differential privacy
by by taking the optimal
you know workload or whatever they call
it for uh differential privacy and and
transforming and
you know transforming it linearly and uh
you know
i assume you could say something similar
here and i was just wondering
i i'm wondering i guess is there
anything interesting to say about it or
is it sort of strange
approach but a guy
so he generalized this approach to
um relaxed definitions of privacy allah
ashwin
is that right i mean so he you know he
was taking rather than
like he was considering a specific set
of relaxations where
instead of allowing me to move my people
around arbitrarily within an
arbitrary l1 change uh there's some
graph that
tells me how i can move mass around
right
in on this l1 in this histogram thank
you you can
relax yeah neighborhood of uh
database view as a histogram like
the comic said you could right right so
that that's why i guess what i'm asking
is maybe that's exactly what he was
doing
was sort of giving the linear
transformation a linear transformation
that maps you know his
convex convex hall of the acceptable
changes according to a given definition
into the the usual l1 ball
right and i guess yeah
i remember he wanted to do something to
the value
according to the value so if the summary
difference is like one billion dollars
so i don't really
care so in that case business
sensitivity will somehow
change when you move around right
right but maybe something can be done
like you know to map it to
histograms here salary would be like
which bin you're in you know you
discretize salaries put people in bins
and it's a you know let's say
multiplicative
bins of of corresponding to different
multiples
okay powers of some small number close
to one right
and then uh you know the acceptable
changes would move you to the adjacency
between the sensitivity it's going to be
the
difference of the difference between
every pair of possible columns of this
workload
and their relaxation of blowfish
privacy from differential privacy it's
it's not necessary that every pair of
columns are
necessary to be sensitive so it's a
redefine
or an ig matrix that that's only
considering certain
pairs of adjacent common statements okay
yes okay yeah funny
sounds like maybe there's some
connection
okay thanks